[Música]
vale muchísimas gracias por invitarme a
montar mundo miedo 2019 a la charla de
tx bueno el tema que vamos a tratar hoy
es china y sus mitos no mi país y lo que
la gente conoce de mi país
primero voy a presentar yo como decía
felipe que tal muy buenas tardes mi
nombre es john seguramente me conoceréis
como el chino un príncipe para corina
el chino de supervivientes o como el
chino de sálvame de luxe no entonces hoy
en día lo que he hecho ya básicamente es
trascender un poquito de ese mundo y
gane bastante dinero y dije voy a
emprender no tengo una empresa como
decía felipe de cargadores y después
tengo otra empresa que nos dedicamos a
un poquito a divulgar la un poquito más
la comunidad china un poquito más la
cultura china y temas de la gastronomía
china no
por eso vengo a hablaros hoy de un tema
muy especial para mí sobre la marca
china la marca china
comparado con marcas vecinas suyas como
puedes si puede ser japón o corea
nosotros cuando escuchamos estos países
como japón y korea nos transmiten muchas
veces la idea de la tecnología el
bienestar la longevidad y muchas veces
en la buena comida la buena salud la
educación y lo que escuchamos sobre
china siempre son cosas un poquito más
negativas
cómo puede ser los productos de mala
calidad la comida barata no como que
puede ser que los chinos somos muy
buenos en las artes marciales pero
realmente no sabemos si estas
informaciones son verdaderas o no
entonces existen ciertos mitos sobre los
chinos vamos a hacer un ejercicio vamos
a levantar la mano los que los que
pensáis que son así los que los que no
pues no las levanten y no bueno quien
piensa o quiera escuchado alguna vez en
su vida que los chinos somos muy buenos
en matemáticas
muy bien quien ha pensado muchas veces
que los chinos comemos perro o lo
escucha alguna vez
si de verdad quiere ha escuchado alguna
vez que los chinos sabemos que un food
hoy quién quiere que deje de hacer
preguntas tontas todo genial entonces de
dónde viene esta información esta
información viene de muchas veces de
amigos cercanos de familiares de la
prensa sobre todo muchas veces de gente
muy importante y muy influyente muchas
veces no y porque me pregunto muchas
veces porque cada vez que sale un mito
siempre sale gente a desmentirlo pero
los mitos sobre los chinos llevan
décadas y décadas y nadie sale a
desmentirlo llegó un poquito tarde pero
pero al menos he llegado no y hoy quiero
desmentir sobre el tema de los mitos si
no es el primero de ellos es que los
chinos no morimos quien quien ha
escuchado esto también mucha gente ya
está
no hace falta agujetas mañana no viene
genial quien ha escuchado este mito
mucha gente es verdad hay un dicho muy
bonito que sea malo y el quicken este
este dicho quiere decir que las hojas
que caen alimentan después a las raíces
pero más allá de todo eso quien se
siente más a gusto donde donde vivió su
infancia
quien recuerdan más bonito de manera más
inocente donde pudo crecer y donde pudo
desarrollar su infancia de manera más
inocente no tuvo que mucha gente de aquí
entonces esto no explica todo realmente
los chinos que vinieron en su época a
trabajar a buscar una vida mejor hoy en
día ya tienen quizás 60-70 años y ya
están en china y están jubilados están
con los amigos de toda la vida de allí
están ya retirados y ellos lo que
quieren básicamente es retirarse o
quizás digamos morirse donde ellos se
sienten más cómodos más identificados
donde ellos sienten que es su hogar
el mito número 2 trata sobre las
matemáticas esto en principio parece que
tiene una connotación muy positiva
dentro de la comunidad china no pero
pero no realmente no yo os voy a decir
por qué
el hecho de que tus compañeros de clase
el hecho de que tus profesores tus
padres tus amigos todo el mundo tenga
unas expectativas sobre ti de que eres
bueno matemáticas de que eres bueno en
equis cosas por ser simplemente chino lo
que hace es que cuando tú no cumplas
esas expectativas realmente cause un
realmente un dolor bastante fuerte auto
autoestima porque la mayoría de las
personas
queremos empatizar y queremos caer bien
queremos conectar con las personas de
manera que hacemos lo que la gente la
gente espera de nosotros no entonces
muchas veces esto genera
a los niños de hoy en día que pierdan su
personalidad por el hecho de querer
complacer las expectativas de los demás
entonces esto es un mito porque
hay 1400 millones de chinos y realmente
no a todos se nos da bien las
matemáticas
el minuto número 3 es algo también
bastante delicado y es el mito sobre que
los chinos sabemos con fe
esto es un precursor bastante potente
para el bullying porque os va a hacer un
escenario y quiero que os lo imagináis
sobre dos chavales que que bueno son
cosas que realmente vivimos muchísimos
chinos en el día a día cuando sobre todo
color es pequeño y os voy a poner el
caso
y tú eres chino seguro que sabes kung fu
luego que de verdad es que no la verdad
que no ha prendido
realmente no sé kung fu que permite una
colleja jaja no pero eso es real señores
eso es de verdad hay mucha gente que
vive este tipo de historias y aunque nos
parezca muchas veces gracioso no es tan
gracioso porque realmente el bullying lo
que genera es depresión ansiedad y todos
estos efectos que lo que hacen es que
hoy en día no podemos tener líderes
potentes que no podamos tener digamos
como se dice emprendedores porque estas
ansiedades lo que hacen es generar aún
muchísimo miedo a muchas veces
expresarse realmente a ser como es
porque siempre vivimos en los prejuicios
de los demás etc
el mito un número cuatro esto es algo
también bastante triste y es el mito de
que los restaurantes chinos en españa'
sirven comida de perro seguramente lo
habéis escuchado todos en china se comen
perros pero la información está digamos
que está mal transmitida lo que
deberíamos de cambiar un poquito el
vocabulario en este aspecto es decir
nosotros deberíamos decir sí que es
verdad que hay gente que en china se
comen perros pero lo que no podemos
hacer es generalizar porque esto cuando
tú generalistas esta idea vale
haces que la gente tenga muchísimos
prejuicios y que cuando un chaval es
joven cuando cuando sus padres le dicen
a sus compañeros y los chinos comen pero
habla este tipo de charlas que a priori
nos parecen muy graciosos generan que
que el chaval ese de origen chino un
paisano mío pues tenga quizás ciertas
dificultades para socializarse con los
demás porque realmente la gente tiene un
pensamiento que no es real que sí que es
verdad que puede suceder pero no es
bueno generalizar siempre no
el mito número 5 que es uno de los más
interesantes es que los chinos somos muy
trabajadores
y yo quiero hacer una reverencia a esto
porque realmente bueno a ver también se
siente más cómodo sentado uno no porque
aparte de pie uno se cansa bastante y
realmente no todos los chinos son muy
trabajadores es verdad que los chinos
que vienen aquí muchas veces son
trabajadores porque ellos vinieron con
un objetivo bien claro los chinos que
han venido aquí han venido con un
objetivo de emprendimiento por causas de
pobreza por causas de crear una vida
mejor etc no y de hecho jackman no sé si
habéis escuchado está desarrollando un
modelo de trabajo de jornada laboral de
que en un futuro dice que se va a
cumplir que es de 12 horas semanales
entonces por favor no tengamos estos
prejuicios porque esto volviendo al tema
también de las expectativas genera
muchas veces cuando una persona china
encuentre un trabajo que haciendo el
mismo trabajo que quizás sus otros
compañeros los jefes se esperan más de
esta persona de origen asiático
entonces voy a ir concluyendo esta foto
es cuando tenía 5 años yo todas y cada
una de estas expectativas y prejuicios
las he vivido en persona mi piel
realmente eso me ha hecho estar durante
un largo tiempo estar en un círculo
encerrado como este pequeñito rojo en el
que muchas veces no sabemos cómo salir
de ahí no sabemos no sabemos digamos de
una manera cómo podemos ser nosotros
mismos cumpliendo las expectativas de
los demás cuando tú eres joven no sabes
cómo manejar las expectativas de los
otros no sabes manejar las emociones que
te generan las otras personas y muchas
veces es muy dañino yo tuve la suerte
realmente de poder levantarme de este
círculo de salir de este círculo y poder
desarrollar mi carrera profesional de
emprender de ser un pequeño líder no
como lo soy hoy en día
y concluyendo un poquito este tema
quiero deciros cómo podemos cambiar
nosotros esto no podemos cambiar
pensando realmente si la información que
nos llega es verídico es cierto si es
solamente una parte de la comunidad
china en la que la que hace las cosas
estas que dicen o si por ejemplo si si
nosotros hoy en día ya hemos escuchado
este discurso y ya sabemos la realidad
sobre los chinos podemos desmentir lo de
vez en cuando cuando saque el tema en la
mesa no bueno y nada muchísimas gracias
mi nombre es john lee y esta es mi
historia
[Aplausos]